and this might just be like a preference
or whatever but what is the cutoff
between because nowadays being big is
is not frowned upon at all it's worth
not worship but it's glorified but when
does it come a point where it's like
you're thick and then you're too big
like
i think it's your body shape to be
honest because you said the statistic is
a lot of women
i want to say well the average woman is
a hundred and
is five five a hundred fifty five pounds
which is like 20 pounds overweight
something like that
yeah over average
no no i i know i know i know yeah yeah
but like the average woman i i i don't
know the exact statistic off the top of
my head but she is overweight yeah yeah
like if you went to a doctor like he
would say yeah i mean
people can say whatever they want like
i'm a curvy like curvier girl like but
women like i know personally like i gain
a lot of weight in my hips like like
such some girls carry it better than
others i know like there's a like for
her like
like genetically women carry more body
fat than men yes
i tend to get gain weight in my hips and
like my birthing area right like that's
where i carry my weight
so that's all like it's they're like you
know what i'm you get what i'm saying so
it's like there's like
yes like but it's all up to preference
like what are you into right you know
right so it's like what really it like
now
well but they're talking like
stick that i think curvy ways big ass
well i think the problem is when we look
at the guys that have all the options to
pick from they all seem to pick the
models
so that says something
and the guys and the guys and the guys
name one billionaire that's not married
to a model or even they're married for
like six seven years and then they get a
divorce and is that what your goal is
not all bill gates jeff bezos both of
their wives were married 20 plus years
they did get a divorce i'm sorry bill
gates wife is not that pretty and same
she wasn't she was when they both
well yeah because that's that's because
they got them young men values white and
white men tend to like thinner women
well they they got them young before
they were even rich
but we could we could take okay who is
kanye dating like we could use different
a part of ones
like i think men with men a lot of the
rich men i can't even state names right
now sorry guys yeah
um a lot of the rich men they go for
models the girls that actually want to
get up get a leg up in the industry get
a leg up in terms of their finances
they're actually working for money
that's your money motivated they go for
rich men the men want them because they
know they can gain that control over
them and that's why it works out i feel
like it's not about anything else well
kim kardashian's also if we're going to
take like a black billionaire like she's
not a black jew
no no no no kanye is a black billionaire
or
she didn't she's she was rich before
kanye yeah no i know i know but you said
you you just said that like those men
pick women with nothing going on
basically so they can control them more
but i'm giving you an example where
that's not true
so i think connie had a huge impact over
kim i feel like with kim but she's
saying that you made this statement
where so i'm saying if you're going to
make that statement like back it up
a lot of men a lot of yeah i can't even
think of names yeah
but they did go for women
that were below them hence in the model
industry like even a lot of right wife
porn stars because they know they want
the money they want the leg up they want
it right right it makes it easier well
because men value different things like
women women like tend to date up
economically so if you if you're making
45 000 like you want a guy that makes
70. of course right but but men just
want a girl that's like fit feminine
friendly that's all they care about yeah
and the model model thing does it for
them yeah for them that's actually like
but i'm just trying to i'm just trying
to understand like the point you're
there like a video making about kanye's
new girl where she was like
yeah because i'm his muse you're like
guys
yeah they broke up
she literally would
her art
background was taking pictures of people
doing heroin while she was on heroin i
mean she's hot and she's
literally made her way
feminine friendly that's all that is all
men care about fit feminine friendly
shins like
that's weird to me
her art was literally people having
drugs
romanticizing
addiction is not weird we could agree
she was crazy like i'm she was
like
i don't think it's control i think it's
they want women that want to work with
them and aren't going to argue with them
every step of the way
women will be submissive to what they
want naturally sometimes as a man you
have to accept being challenged
sometimes yeah and i feel like because
men have a harder time stepping out of
their own perspective they don't yeah
they're not as accepting when it comes
to hearing a woman's opinion on
something especially if it's not
something that they're super
uh
knowledgeable about you know
so
sometimes it is a control thing for men
i think but not always well i think i
think when you get to like i think when
you get to be like a one percent guy
right he's he's top five percent
whatever they run multi-million dollar
businesses they probably know a lot of
[ __ ] you don't to be honest unless
you're on that same level but like
if i was dating a guy that's a
billionaire or a millionaire i would
trust his judge i'm sorry you have to
remember that that's the one percent you
know how many of us are really gonna
touch the one percenter right i'm gonna
be the one like that's a combination of
you're super you're very clearly
super intelligent but that's also luck
like not everyone is super intelligent
makes it so it's kind of like oh it's
not you're right it's partially luck but
i have not seen many people make a 20 30
year career without being somewhat smart
and subway driven right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like you know it's like five minutes of
fame right like a year two years
okay wait um okay so the next super chat
so none of you would taking a spanking
from your significant other i'm not i'm
not i mean
okay yesterday this this show to make
this educational and y'all trying to
make it about sex
please relax